this 1990 movie is so 1990 even 1991 is
making fun of it ah 1990 when
pickpocketing was still something that
could be considered a crime wave even
more alarming is the baffling and often
bizarre nature and this is a long-winded
newscast isn't it here we have the first
example of a classic 1990s martial arts
in I like to call because ninjas I don't
know where this TV is plugged in and it
doesn't matter but the thief took off
with this TV without unplugging it
because she can still hear the TV even
as he takes it away from her
only a few vague reports of young boys
or teenagers that the scenes have been
filed Catholic priests have also been
spotted at the scenes this entire crime
syndicate is built on profits similar to
that of a local pawnshop
oh haha Ghostbusters reference April
O'Neill isn't a porn star in this scene
first off woman sees a rat and climbs on
something cliche second if you lived in
New York for any time at all you see
rats all the time and should be used to
this third the rat ran into the drain
and is already gone now so why did you
do that bedtime what are you talking
about this is excellent timing at least
if we want the turtles to show up and I
bet they say ton of money on this scene
by shooting it all in the dark cops in
New York City respond to a random
mugging that no one put in a 9-1-1 call
about
well it's 1990 still trying to shake off
the 80s none of us have heard from Kurt
Cobain yet we didn't know any better no
Andy Serkis and motion capture
technology weren't available yet for
this movie you see in this at least for
another 15 minutes of movie time
then you may lapse these starving Pizza
Living Ninja Turtles just returned from
their first fight and ordered only one
medium pizza in my horrible 1990 Domino
standards Domino's should not be pleased
with a look of this pizza geez when was
this movie made there's a theater still
playing in 1986 b-movie classic critters
also obvious turtle in the costume is
ignored gonna be that kind of movie a
that was a crime Nupur scrub in pukes
human vigilante goes after two
purse-snatchers that have already been
reprimanded by another vigilante a Jose
Canseco bat tell me you didn't pay money
for this and this movie was ages ahead
of the rest of Hollywood and realizing
Canseco was a nut job
that's impressive no sin hasty TV street
interview somehow has multi camera
editing between the reporter and the
police captain are you denying that such
an organization known as the foot exists
shredder orders April O'Neil killed but
despite being really easy to find at on
to the news station or the antique shop
where she lives the foot apparently
can't find her anywhere to finish the
job this is the City Hall stop and
absolutely no one is on the platform
except April did anyone even get off the
last train and no one who wants to go
the other direction
ninja let's another ninja track and
follow him all the way back to the
hideout Wow he stumbled on four baby
turtles and a broken vial of radioactive
ooze at the same time that's a
red-letter day for a sewer rat I tell
you the chief of police himself is the
one calling random shoplifters parents
and is doing so 12 hours or more after
the arrest we interrupt this ninja
turtle movie to bring you an
after-school special so this is the
Ninja Turtle version of Pinocchio's land
of toys but instead of turning into
donkeys they turn into a Foot Clan
ninjas this kid decides I can do
whatever the hell I want so forget
uncomfortably sleeping on arcade
machines and living the dream I don't
care how criminal this operation is that
is a sloppy ass roulette table that
dealer is surely getting robbed
frequently
anything how about dismembering you
right now that's cool how about if I
pray for you will you literally tolerate
anything this guy can do anything and
once at all and when he comes up with
his smoke cigarettes these kids don't
immediately murder their friend for
saying read em and weep
getting beaten up by a redhead this guy
went to the Cobra Kai dojo for his
training
shredder Bane did anyone hear how that
sounded when they were filming this
movie oh good
splinter is still alive which is
probably surprising to five-year-olds
but why do they need to keep them alive
they don't even tell the turtles they
have it I'm sorry the foot april O'Neil
will be here all week ladies and
gentlemen not that this guy is terrible
but you know he would have killed in
this role Stephen Tobolowsky this guy is
a discount Stephen Tobolowsky
very much that chief Stern's is taking
this possible connection seriously
professional reporter April O'Neill
suddenly becomes April O'Reilly what is
out there somewhere the question is how
do you know you clearly thought he was
dead because you were crying there's not
even been one scene where you guys have
said we need to find splinter he's so
obviously been kidnapped by that Foot
Clan fight fight kitchen kitchen movie
let's these two characters escape the
boring fight but doesn't extend the same
courtesy to the audience oh that's great
over the top sarcasm is over the top
in a really tragic history of movie
characters being separated after
fighting over stupid reasons this is the
Treasure Coast
Raphael takes out his anger on the roof
in broad daylight also anger gymnastics
also this rooftop venting session is fun
but it makes me realize Raphael is the
only turtle of the four to get any
character development whatsoever the
rest I'll have to split up a few food
and pop-culture related references and
call it a day guy who fought Raphael
earlier just happens to be on the top of
roof where he can see Raphael again
superhero sits on the edge of a tall
building and overlooks the city he
protects cliche buncha ninjas sneak up
on a better ninja because he's
emotionally distracted haha Turtles
watching Turtles
the bridge ninja fighting yeah it's the
one every bad guy in every movie studies
with the chapter don't attack one by one
ripped out don't worry about the numbers
though only one of these guys is
actually going to fight you at any given
moment yes yes it is
they have TV shows about people like you
let go he'll probably be back any minute
convenient dialogue timing is convenient
also ninjas who were trying to kill
Raphael throw him through a glass window
instead of just continuing to gang up on
it Oh nunchuck rap battle also everyone
waits during this bullet instead of
fighting Donatello jumps and hits a
couple guys and in the next couple shots
it looks like they'd taken out roughly
90% of the ninjas and three punches this
fishtank bolts yeah we're getting our
asses kicked but it's only because of
the weapons we chose to use also this
asshole is just standing outside the
door with an armful of axe sword just
waiting for his chance to shine
did April get down here and who the fuck
was this guy and what is he doing again
with the symbols man this movie gets
more mileage out of symbols than
drumline and not only did April get down
here during the fight she somehow
dragged Raphael down here with her in a
fight with over 30 actual ninjas a non
ninja human being with a hockey stick
will now make a difference Wayne Gretzky
on steroids
nope not until he pulls out his jose
canseco bat wow more than making a
difference this non ninja human being
will now successfully take on over a
dozen trained real ninjas on his own no
it's not bitch the electricity was
severed remember you're fired oh I see
the exposition took over where
electricity left off and powered the
answering machine long enough for the
audience and Casey to hear this
important information Casey Jones uses
the power of closing a door to keep
ninjas out abduction ban wait a minute
that's the building they were in so how
did Raphael get on the roof of this
building after yelling at Leonardo and
how did the footnote to ninja their way
to the top of this same building when it
was the antique shop they needed to go
to all wrong there's a point where the
ninjas throw fil through the skylights
but when you look at the building now
where is the weight taller building that
all that action could have taken place
off asshole red-haired kid is red hair
yah-ha shredder asks a question
threatens splinter with a blade to the
throat but then immediately gives
splinter an indefinite deadline to live
because the script car breaks down but
only at the exact moment they reached
their destination thank you No thank you
for that privilege right human male
entering the pictures suddenly becomes
April O'Neill's love interest after a
few seconds of screen time you see kids
back in the 80s there was a show called
moonlighting it had Bruce Willis and
Cybill Shepherd in it don't know who
Cybill Shepherd is neither did kids back
then it's strange being back on the old
farm whoa whoa whoa she's just gonna
start narrating like we haven't already
sent through 52 minutes of movie my
amazing new friends have suffered their
first real defeat you call that a defeat
they beat up like a hundred guys and
only one turtle got hurt April is
drawing a picture of something she has
no idea is happening movie rips off the
two characters that actually like each
other treat insults thing from
wreckit-ralph wait a second unconscious
turtle storage 90s music training
montage our master is still kidnapped
and being tortured but let's practice
this script is 20% puns telepathy ex
machina our master still kidnapped and
being tortured but let's play Trivial
Pursuit our masters still kidnapped and
being tortured but let's make s'mores
always midi-chlorians
what rooster is still growing at this
long abandoned farm it's time to go back
well truthfully it's way the past time
to go back but whatever of all the
places in the whole of New York City for
redheaded kid to hide he chooses the
turtles hideout which of course he's
never seen in this movie or had any idea
existed let alone the whereabouts of
this extreme stretch to make a gay joke
must have been in the margins of the
script somewhere written in pencil but
they went ahead and filmed it anyway kid
who rejected the foot and has been
living alone down in the sewers for
several days suddenly starts having
second thoughts nightmares about being
evil Danny came to live in the sewers
for a while Casey Jones is suddenly
claustrophobic so he sleeps in the truck
in an incredibly perfect situation is
created where he finds Shredder's lair
through dumb luck then making his
movements from my cage splinter repeats
a part of the story we've already heard
before but has nothing to do with the
story he's about to tell so what's like
his katana slicing my ear
vengeful murderer decides to keep around
alive because that's the Warriors code I
guess whatever happened to this or
Okazaki no one really knows what you
wear his symbol upon your brow I mean
he's probably the dude with the mass
that calls himself shredder but what
proof do I have is it lying hiding
something
pieces Keita's a never-ending river of
black convenience isn't he
shredder learns the turtles are back and
is so upset about it that he forgets to
punish the infidel that ran away live
with the Turtles bonded enough to wanna
throwing as a keepsake and then lied to
his face which is a good thing because
he's able to eavesdrop and find out that
splinter is scheduled for execution also
why didn't you do this before you never
even gave the Turtles ransom demands or
threatened them with his death or
anything just because you can go through
the drain does not mean you should go
through the drain also are they just
falling face-first into the sewer after
they do that what could they possibly
hold on to that would make this safe for
some reason Tatsu decided to bring all
the rest of the bad kids with him when
he went to go kill splitter instead of
just going ahead and doing it movie
thinks it can earn back points by
casting Sam Rockwell far ahead of his
fame and actual coolness and you know
what movie is right take once in all
four Rockwell family you you call this
and that down there family this bullet
somehow converts the bad kids to good
kids boobie calls itself in its own
cliches cliche also 37 seconds of turtle
puns massive fight scene makes its way
from the street to the roof for a big
finale as fight scenes are known to do
good it seems the turtles have also been
reading from the abridged book of ninja
fighting to the four of them could have
overpowered him before they all decided
to fight him one by one surprise reveal
comes from the Wolverine school of
surprise reveals
I began what you own I stopped at your
ear because storytelling that's actual
murder you just went from good guys to
sociopaths just Daniel okay kid who
basically just played ex machina the
whole movie decides he's had some
character growth now what in God's name
happened out here tonight
check out the east warehouse over the
libman island get your answers there now
we won't
I mean he'll figure out that all the
stolen goods are over there but there's
nothing that will explain anything about
the fight that just happened you
literally took the only good guy male
and female characters and decided to
have them fall in love because people
falling in love tests well or some am i
right time's up three bucks off
my little buttercup has the sweetest a
jose canseco fat tell me you didn't pay
money for this this is me I think it's a
parent I need to rethink my life a
little bit what's my problem first of
all I'm a rat one of them spoke I make
more than enough money to provide for
both of us and you're stealing why you
don't know you are right
I learned it by watching you take
control take control of your city this
this is the instrument of your
liberation
punished
Master I like turtles you're not gonna
die on the planet guy I'm not what's my
last name nobody knows you know why
because my character isn't important
enough for a last name because I'm gonna
die
you probably already know you can
acts into your home just by visiting
naturebox compliments but you know who
doesn't the Ninja Turtles actually
they're really the ideal customer for
nature box first they're teenagers and
teenagers are always hungry it's got
thirty Seconds second being teenagers
and having eaten entirely too much pizza
in their young lives Turtles could
benefit from the massive diversity of
options naturebox has to offer seriously
they have all kinds of stuff third each
and every box that I've received has
come with five different snacks inside
with four turtles and one rat sensei in
the household five is the perfect number
fourth and finally these are crime
fighting Turtles on the go they pretty
much need the convenience that comes
with to your door delivery which
thankfully naturebox offers free of
charge you should try it yourself before
the turtles get there and clean out the
warehouse and one afternoon just go to
nature box Commons delicious healthy
snacks delivered right to your door with
free shipping seriously but honestly
can't believe you're still watching this
video instead of serving the nature box
website